back from nollans oh I forgot you were
there say this about nollans now you
know I got my case of psoriasis and I'm
on a diet
so you get that job in New Orleans I I
didn't I don't know the truth is I don't
know where I got it and I got my wife
your wife my wife said don't wear that
shirt on its own but you can wear it
under a sweater where you have a little
piece of this your sweater or anything
where you have a piece of this showing
like hanging out yeah she said so you
know that there's a problem we have
roots are my eyes your toast of all it
hurts my eyes please please hold on your
shoes it goes with your shoes but listen
when you have a shirt and they say just
let a little bit that's not it's too
much yeah right little like that shirt
you can let a little tiny like an inch
dangle in the back and then were you
like can I get the wizard sleeves do you
guys have a ten wizard well because I
like to keep things under my sleeves
like bunnies pigeons and knives and then
when I pickpocket and crowds I like it
dude and you know as long as I like it
like I have character will never wear
that shirt again after this I get it as
soon as I say one thing you know you
know it doesn't look it's right through
I read you came in or like Kyle
hopefully sir what's up I feel like
camera well what are we doing man I
don't have much of an eye for fat it's
my eyes don't have an eye for fashion do
I that's just not your thing bro I'm not
on it though all right can we move on
yeah man well you never win I get by
moving I do you mean and I'll never wear
that again
it's funny how your eye is like it you
you're like my buddy Johnny Frechette
who is a an artist and he goes he's
sitting there and he goes I gotta get
out of here I go what he goes I got a
guy here and why we're at the hanging
out he goes no no I mean LA I said why
and he goes it's too ugly man I'm always
fixing things with my eyes it's just
that look at that dog why would they
make that building like that so when you
have an eye for fashion you have an eye
for architecture it's very hard on your
eyes stuff with driving me nuts
yeah the colors off if that comes off
how your brain works yeah that's like a
talent that you probably had since you
were a little kid yeah I don't notice it
like if you asked me what color
somebody's shirt was I don't even notice
we're all blind in certain ways like I
don't pay attention like you know went
like you so if you buy Mercedes or let's
say you buy a Porsche amazing car yeah
but if it's so if you there's a regular
curve
there's a crass there's the GTS yeah
well if you if I used to just have a
Carrera well when I look at a career and
I look at next to GTS there are two
completely different cars right but I
think most of you would look at yo the
same car yeah but all I can see if I saw
him pass the road I pick out everything
that this car doesn't have yeah I would
drive me [ __ ] now it's amazing it's
like Ange it's like a mother with two
identical twins she knows immediately
who the difference is for us any age
have you have a knife or something it's
a problem you pick up on that yeah right
away blessing in the curse
yeah well it's just having a what's
called a sophisticated or cultivated I
yeah they say it's like it's like my
father can tell you the difference
between composers when they're playing
the same Tchaikovsky sonata oh really
yeah like they're playing the same song
and he'll go I don't like the way this
was oh well and a lot of people can do
must listen to a lot of oh yeah yeah but
a lot of people can a lot of people who
are it's a cultivate of the ear what to
call the vision they pick up sure or
what I think is incredible is like
conductors can literally have so let's
say in the average Orchestra there are I
don't know eight violins ten violas five
horns seven trembling it's how many how
many instruments would just have [ __ ]
load like 34 squad he can go like this
good conductors can do this they can go
second horn hold on nuts off you're off
that's we don't see that's what they can
do I know I get another Factory bad
conductors yeah did you know that they
have the longest lifespan because their
arms are above their heart so that's why
they have the loss that's true yeah
that's the weirdest thing I've ever
heard not weird another factory
you know they [ __ ] zero girls did you
know that come on you don't know that
did you know they get no [ __ ] did you
know about those guys
do you know those guys make your girl
drive faster no they probably get an
engine they probably get they get
musician girls who are good at the
violin and the piano no no no is nothing
their leaders nothing looks lamer than
this well bands are in the air like this
yeah but they have the longest lifespan
really yep out of all jobs come on man
that's amazing because their arms above
their heart which is healthy they're
this uh this somebody I know
it's true right somebody I know is
friends with Wynton Marsalis the great
jazz a maestro the great dancer no he's
a great he's a jazz composer okay with
the considered one of the greatest jazz
trumpeters in the world of all time in
fact of course but Harry Connick jr.
said he does things technically on a
trumpet that's not are not supposed to
be done possible for a human being like
the way his fingers do it yeah it said
crazy and he because he's a jazz
musician and in jazz you listen to all
different instruments and you're
communicating with him apparently he can
listen to for conversations when he is
at dinner
oh wow he can listen to fortified
positions at the same time and and still
pick up yes yeah and then he'll get up
and like like um he'll wake up and if
you're if you're talking to him or
something like you're saying something
and you're having a conversation like
his this girl I know used to date him
she got up she was said something she
complained about something none of that
and he didn't listen to really what she
heard her but he played the music he
played the tone of her voice on the
trumpet he just picked his troubled up
he listener she goes something like this
you know you didn't let me finish my
sentence last night kind of really
bothered me and as far as I'm concerned
I think you need to be more respectful
what was that just played you yeah
knowing just a way of communicating
buddy that's pretty crazy it's just why
I'm gonna take my trumpeting a lot more
serious now I wonder if he can text and
talk is it the hardest thing you do in
the world like when you're trying to
write a serious Texas welcome you
everyone shuts down they say you're not
really able to do two things at once
multitask yeah girl women are better at
than men they say well that makes sense
cuz when they say I mean woman's well
that makes sense because a woman has to
keep her child alive while he's doing
something kick cook food keeps [ __ ]
clean like oh I see the way my wife does
it she's got two kids to keep track of
all they do a thousand other things too
yeah we're more statistically a better I
guess they've actually done Studies on
that where they say men because men's
minds women have to do that they have to
multitask just just to keep the child
alive men because I can't rely on men
let's be honest they just can't to keep
the child live for the most part
historically men can obsess on one thing
so men can go on thing you only yeah
they can go off
yeah kids need food yeah [ __ ] off I'm in
my office I'm gonna figure out I'm gonna
study and obsess over why time bends or
space bends or whatever it is and so
obsess over naho then literally that's
why that that was why dumb the meal
pagli was like why why have so many men
been ones revolutionized the human
condition it's like well women were kept
down but there's another reason then
have different brains they can obsess
over one thing women have multifaceted
brains just different interesting by the
way I was radically incorrect I was
shooting in New Orleans though I had to
drive a car Bren
how many days were you shooting I drove
I thought for one day but just Sunday or
so now what you do and when you should
have your shoot on the Lord's Day Sean
on the Lord's Day movies doomed I did
shoot on the Lord's Day say no more Pham
now hold on he's shot on the Lord's Day
I did movies bust really mm-hmm
I said my prayers I got there I got
there at 6 and an obscene it what you do
is you want to get there at 5 actually
5:30 a.m.
you know 5:30 p.m. if you get there 5:30
p.m. you're gonna be shooting it at 12
midnight see that's all eight night
there's always a light there's always a
long they bring you in at least five
hours early on film yeah make sure you
there yeah make up all that stuff I
don't know maybe shots a shot from
midnight to what time it was a short
scene it was just a driving scene where
we had to hear some stuff and he was
came in just for that and then you left
the Monday morning yeah offered a part
in Wonder Woman - I told you that and
turned it down I had to turn it down why
too busy hold on leave me [ __ ] you I
know I know but go back let's rewind
why'd you turn it down now tell me the
truth
got them doing a movie though there's no
time for my yep I'm getting ready for my
I'm already signed up for that I can't I
can't
it's a thirteen million dollar movie I
can't walk away from it Wonder Woman
Stan and Stan and it's a good part and a
funny part it's a disaster for me but
but it would be a long time in DC how
could hold down this fort and I
guarantee if we told all the fans some
might appreciate it if you took a break
for five weeks excuse me sir
no I'm just saying are you trying to
[ __ ] replay no not at all on Blom
safety line I guess
yeah I get to you if we told the fans
hey Brian shooting Wonder Woman - so
he's not gonna be in town for five weeks
so it's gonna be Brennan and guests are
Theo von
so what we're gonna do it's gonna be
Brendon my god weeks yeah I don't want
to say there'd be an uproar of happiness
but I think everyone would understand
and then I think everyone understand
when you get that text two weeks and it
says hey bro don't bother coming back
I'm I'm hurt and I'm so replace no I'm
just saying for reals though and take
your hands up don't touch me like that
again
don't touch me you have your psoriasis
still getting oh [ __ ] man
come on yeah [ __ ] come on dude Nutter
dude million my life my thoughts like a
million predators ray my thighs better
hey but for reals if you said hey dude I
got part on 102 it's a big parts gonna
be one of the biggest movies ever and
I'm gonna be gone for five weeks you
hold down the fort I'd say yes we at
least through at least one a week maybe
pursue and you could do it I pretty sure
so you turned it down why now cuz I
guarantee if they don't hate shop we
need just the next Batman but you're
gone for six months yeah Brendan just
look at me
Brendan what what do you mean what I
gotta fight kid I'm Batman
Brendan the mothership bat man like what
am I brennick hello Brendan and then
hives Britain's agent he's the new oh my
god Oh through his age he you've changed
you got too busy well I'm under contract
for that other movie yep
and also I have Patti could we've made
the off a little earlier so could have
figured this out oh I know but she was
working so hard to find me this part
name and who's who's playing opposite me
Jimmy Burke Oh Jimmy Burke we're playing
- I can't say what we're playing but
your best friends in it I know Jimmy
Burke phone you got a gig yeah and
you're not doing it I know I don't want
to talk about it oh my god I did bring
it up
yeahyou I didn't know all this I know
ken right part for the big man huh hey
come on
dear don't get greedy the toss and rolls
around left and right hard thing here
and I mean ha throw a bone no we're not
totally a bad guy
cheeky one bad guy keke keke keke good
bad guy how would you play a bad guy
alright say this well no I could be I
could be like the guy who seduces her
and then I but I'm trying to get her I
don't watch one room I'm trying to get
her belt or some [ __ ] you gotta realize
I tell you we gotta do you gotta get my
money so ask me where my money is I'm
gonna give you an excuse and then I want
you to look at me and go I want you to
get I want you to I want you to come
back with something I want you to just
kind of tell me that I'm gonna lose my
hands alright but I'll lose your hands
well I'm do it in a very non aggressive
way yeah you ready yeah do have an
accent
nope here is my money no I want you to
do it really really menacingly no that
was your size don't be a big no we're
sitting down and people listening so
they can't hear that you don't need to
move you're a huge guy I'm not gonna
move I'm he's reading I'm gonna Villa is
my monday are you uh are you Dracula I'm
mysterious you don't know are you a
Dracula who wrestles huh Boise can't
unless the movie so get ready was my mum
Vera is my Monday I'm sorry I couldn't
understand you sir dude this is the
movie weird I'm gonna get off setting
gear until then young tot can we can we
get a replacement for I to God try again
ask me for my money I'm gonna give you
an excuse and then I want you to I want
you to not accept the excuse but don't
but I want you to be menacing you're a
bag not in my Russian now I want you to
ask me here here's your doing as an
actor get the money from me let me know
let me know that if I don't have your
money in 12 hours I won't be I won't be
you I won't be I won't I'll be handless
okay alright alright where's my money
okay um you don't seem serious cuz you
seem like god damn it Brian
well you're not laughing well this is
even working look like you're about to
laugh God and write one more but I would
say I'll give you an excuse
I'm trying yeah where's my [ __ ] money
okay I'm glad you asked that I'm gonna
tell you this I'm gonna have your money
have your money really soon I don't have
your money right now because the bank
doesn't they need literally 24 hours to
get my money and I'm gonna get it for
you so just let me go let me go get the
money okay why are you laughing I'm
gonna get you your money I just need 24
hours all I hear is blah blah blah okay
you're not intimidating at all I know it
sorry yeah and it'd be tough to play a
bad guy for good right yeah has to be
comedy yeah sorry man they could figure
out one woman though that's a bummer man
if you need five weeks I told you i text
you he said hey kid might be doing
wonder when I said don't worry about the
podcasts all hold it why not watch take
all the bed watch out watch how watch
how I get my money watch this watch how
casual I am about it
Oh weird you been acting for 30 years
please do not let's just watch how I
know you can do it
hey man how you doing I'm all right yeah
I know yeah my my I don't see my mom I
know just shade [ __ ] mouth so my mom
my mom took the money cause she ain't
pay the bills
and then I your mom did mm-hmm and then
my sister need food and then I need a
new shirt okay so I'll get it tomorrow
okay I'm trying to say is I'll get it
tomorrow
okay you know what you know what let me
suck your dick nope not my time tell you
what I'm gonna do for you I'm gonna give
you 12 hours but listen if I don't get
the money in twelve hours which is a lot
of time and it's no big deal I know I
know I'm gonna get the money in twelve
hours doesn't work I know buddy get the
money
yeah no doubt right because I know that
and you know that if I don't get the
money in 12 hours your sister and your
mom or your brother train sister place
you're gonna trade on them she's not
gonna have hands I'm gonna walk around
no hands I know it sucks it's terrible
and you will not be able to help them
because you won't have feet
you know I'm saying but good news is
they'll have they'll have four feet and
you'll have two hands
and you guys will have to live together
into a circuit worst part of that is
that's again your sister give you a real
I mean they're exhausting to be around
aren't they yeah I don't like you so
let's you're gonna kill them for me no I
got Caliphate I don't aim to do that I'm
gonna I'm gonna cut their hands mmm then
I'm gonna have hands off I'm gonna cut
your feet off cool okay but we're not
gonna get to that are we no cuz you can
have my money in 12 hours are correct
and that do me a favor
Cantonese suck open your mouth
don't finish my sentence this one no I'm
excited for this in the movie I'd be
excited for that now I'm not gonna have
you touch my Wang I don't trust you but
my rump I'm a bunny hush now my bunny
hole needs a swab if you don't think a
bad guy called the bunny hole I call my
bunny home see now you see now you seem
friendly we see the buddy and I want to
be I want to sound friendly you and New
York before New Orleans again last week
I did oh did I tell you how am i oh you
know private gig I thought I had a
private gig I'd say how I went no okay
it was probably seven table for us 100
of the top lawyers in the country all
their whole in the world in the world
they're hilarious
yeah I'm never doing I'm not doing
corporate gigs anymore you are I'm gonna
shut your mouth and go there with a
smile and while I can checkered shirt a
wall I guess gay sailor don't tell jokes
I had I was in a suit first mistake oh
you did comedy ensue I did a big mistake
who told you do that in loafers why did
you use a pole to do that by who by the
you never tells you what company that
hired me not only that there were
certain things that I needed I know the
guy who put it on great guy and a
listener of the show great guy he was
awesome love it would see the one who
gave you that his son and here at fans
camera his name may be Michael but
Michael didn't give you the advice to
wear a suit and loafers no - Michael
mine was very cool but out of respect
because it was black tie it suggested
your comic I know that now dirty what
that was also emceeing
I know I told some jokes I give the
award first award tall woman taller than
me stern-looking looks at me and says
you were very offensive I said what part
she said the whole
thing gross and offensive and her friend
said you have a long way to go and I
went I was thank you very much
Wow and that's how it started after
doing ten minutes of comedy and nobody
laughed for my ten minutes oh my I mean
crickets have you ever seen that happen
to me I have that happen to me and
where's hold on
never Craig never crickets and part of
us just the venue part of its I didn't
feel comfortable because it's a
corporate gig they don't buy
uncomfortable situations you still make
people laugh but your gift yes I did
they were lawyers and they were all
partners and I think some of them didn't
want to laugh at some of the risque
stuff I was saying it wasn't dirty it
was just it was just you know it was
funny and crushes and only he taught was
better the Tebow charity event where
there's dying kids in the back and you
dirty jokes or this one by far better oh
wow can you believe that because that
was a bad that was tough
Wow yeah I just can't do those this is
my thing be why do it you're not
strapped for cash yeah why why you'd all
down your I learned I learned I'm not
gonna do it anymore because I'm
compromising myself and I mean yeah
about myself yeah yeah it doesn't any
feel like another I've never done a
corporate gig where I felt comfortable I
feel like I'm doing it for the money I'm
working for the man I'm working for a
corporation that's not that's not really
but that doesn't work with comedy the
reason cop comics are no Mets are you
gonna do what you like what you want to
say if you like it you buy a ticket to
the show if not all right but this is
the cup of crank but now the corporates
going hey Brian we like you so we're
gonna bring in but we're bringing it
under these conditions yes
wear a suit wear these loafers and don't
do this material do this material well
that's not gonna do that
go go get someone else right there's two
other guys who are great at yes there
are they're not our friends but they're
great at sad that's also not funny
they're great at that that's not you I
know and you're not struggling come with
some new comic you struggling for money
I know so do me a favor don't take a
seven-hour flight in a [ __ ] suit and
loafers where they're not gonna laugh at
your comedy for a paycheck that's a
bummer I know it was they paid me a
million dollars oh so that's that's a
hard to say well now I'm on board I know
I won't do a lot for a million dollars
no - so you so you were the old gold
your there but then that night you got
that did you get to get
and then see people you've been in New
York oh yeah I was without I was with
mr. Duff Davidoff mr. Jimmy Burke mr.
Tarr Kazim ourselves laughs yes you were
mr. stark and dove just get along like
guitarist Eric loves dove tart Ark was
well tarik was like dude I want to I
want to be because all you need in life
is Jimmy Birkin and dove Davidoff I said
that's correct that's correct correct
those are the two guys you need yes
tarik was like I want to I want to be
here yeah you don't I'll of being around
because I don't need to say anything I
can just listen Jimmy never oh the best
yeah story lobster I'm Zen he's
hilarious Doug others the the the the
super instrument is yes we went to dove
took me and Tareq and Jimmy to two
galleries in Chelsea that sell Modern
Art okay now we went in and there was uh
there was a neon sign it was three three
words stacked on top is just neon it
said jungle jungle jungle oh yeah okay
yeah I bought that piece how much do you
think it was jungle forty five grand
yeah there's three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars oh wow $300,000 for a
just in the UH Thunder jungle jungle
that's right that's right did JLo like
that that's there there was that then we
went in and there was just a bunch of
wood stacked on top of each other by
this guy named Andre something and that
was some inordinate amount of money and
then there were just a bunch of frames
of like if you if you if you typed out
he over and over again in a block and
then you typed out I over and over again
they typed out she over and over again
and if you frame those in regular shitty
wooden frame that would cost you fifty
thousand I gotta head to New York start
doing some painting Jim but Dov goes and
it's all in this huge warehouse with
like this skylight yeah that was like so
if oh this place is infuriating they
hang string from a ceiling just string
from a ceiling and that would cost you
at least $100,000 I'm not it's crazy so
Douglas it's amazing I told joke it fell
flat but then I told it again and again
in a [ __ ] huge room of the skylight
now pay me it's exactly the same thing
it's ridiculous it's on modern art is
the biggest joke in the world yeah we
sure man also don't show up and hate on
it though 300,000 don't know that come
on some things are so absurd and then
the fact that people are willing to pay
almost half a million dollars for it but
whose fault is it if there's a market
for it you know I'm saying well it's
just you don't you're paying for it yeah
it's crazy yeah well people just want to
be part of a club that gets it that's
what it is if I'm not artists I'm paying
for that I'm you know I'm saying I'm
making it as a demand yeah some of this
stuff is great but out of it some yeah
so he's gonna be bars I went to uh
Disneyland on Friday with Klopp Klopp
and the kids design all-day stay the
night there decide to have a cheat day
ate everything in sight threw up at the
parade so that was fun I think her sex
you said to me said hashtag definitely
not making it to 50 correct I said in
hashtag enjoy me now yep hashtag enjoy
me now hashtag definitely not making it
to 50 correct definitely yeah you got me
a little worried WC I'm down to 50
before 50 and then threw up their
Saturday open for joy Diaz how's that
fun good he's getting ready to shoot his
Netflix special and then so then I went
to sunnier that candy topi played Santa
Monica know what's like a huge candy
Ville I'm sure a man does sort of it
kids know it they have like these huge
statue sleeps be a modern art like huge
statues made of candy we have a whole
mushroom pool yeah it's pretty cool
there's candy for all the kids that's
cool
yeah it's pretty fun I was a clop all
weekend man it's good to see him I wish
he lived - I know uh and you got sick
you ate what did you eat everything name
some names name a product at churros oh
yeah this is the problem the Klopp Klopp
is like me right and he's always on a
diet and then I was like dude you're on
a diet at Disneyland right you know it
starts one person goes what do you let's
do it so cops a big dude and he's always
on a diet I said dude no diet today
right kids are here let's stuff fun when
I can find healthy food anyway so let's
eat whatever I've been pretty strict so
I think it makes it worse when I'm
straight great and so I just went
outside a churro
my son need a water so I went to this
place like we need to buy something like
what do you offer chili cheese dog I'll
take it eight
it had chicken tenders had loads of
coffee a candy cotton candy more churros
here and then by the time Prague campus
in AB honoring
there's no Cinnabon I wish they would
have oh you kidding me I'd live for
Cinnabon you just go the middle crazy if
it's dough and sugar you're going crazy
you're calling which I haven't been I've
been good but then parade came around
and we got to the Beauty and the Beast
part of it which we've been waiting two
hours for remind you if the Pixar's big
parade all the ships are waiting for and
Belle came out the crowd went well
wild wild wow yeah it was craziest big
things this a real lady is up there
waving and almost yeah I thought this
perfect time to hurl cuz everyone's not
paying attention so when she went yeah I
won the Backlund walk everywhere
cuz the sight of Belle and she probably
saw you and said why is that handsome
guy throwing up at me nope I looked down
when it right on the girl you say your
fault well I said you the real beast
girl would it be a distraction cuz it
worked
had some great rides to the what they're
doing like the toys right they have
there I'm sorry not toys the monsters
ride is sake my things go on that you
know what
don't bring a two-year-old on the
Haunted Mansion nope oh my gosh they
can't be on God and they've redone it I
brought him on they're kind of a bad
ideas cuz yeah my son the same thing
he's not scared of anything like we're
gonna have someone which is dark and
they can get a little scary Little
Mermaid gets a little scary he thrives
off that Haunted Mansion when it's all
scary he's like probably not I'm too
moral it's not gonna he's too little
my son same thing I took him on
something like that content something
holy [ __ ] yeah I mean a crisis a crisis
you got to be careful and then the next
morning were you know the we said the
Disney hotel we're all there and they
have this buffet and it's just it's the
[ __ ] of the [ __ ] food their ingredients
can you put a little effort into just
quality ingredients the worst and then I
get backlash from everyone cuz I'm
hating on the food I'm like I'm not
eating this I'm just I'll just wait tell
you at home I've coffee like your show
bougie just I'm like I spent I spent the
entire day the previous eating
everything in sight yeah it's the worst
food in the world that's why I'm sick
yeah and I like quality food I don't
want to eat this stuff like oh come on
man like dude I just want to eat it
the [ __ ] food may horrible forever yak
Franklin an oil and [ __ ] gots just
horrible
the eggs were faked and I'm in real eggs
yeah those the baby eggs right what a
little [ __ ] effort in that the bacon
looks like silly string but brown god oh
it sucks
I don't like screws that my wife was
playing around I was like not getting on
a cruise and eating that food I'll be
stuck and I'll go crazy I can know if I
can do it for one day I'm good any line
that I freaked the [ __ ] yeah I got home
I jumped on that peloton bike burned
about 1,400 calories hardest I've ever
gotten rode hard huh oh dude felt super
sick put a bandana on you wear a little
head strap I put a band down on slappy
look the club's budget gloves I get the
shoes I do have the shoes yeah you know
what those bands you put around your
body to monitor your heart and [ __ ] have
a watch I said does it cuz June 18 ma
what are you wearing you're in your ass
in my ass I put a plunge okay
we call it the riders plunge all right
as long as nothing drips good just keep
you stimulated and ready so no honnest
it keeps you honest
it's nothing group it groups keeps keeps
pressure on the prostate yeah good good
good good
I like it are you out of town this week
too I I am it was nice at Monday off
right ones that someone took him Monday
off
let's have Memorial Day I was very nice
actually I'm glad I flew back very early
for the podcast I know you did my talk
but then I figured yeah you were back
early for the podcast it's a nice break
I had I'd work Saturday night with Gia's
Sunday at the fight campaign yet so I'm
like dude I don't want to get I feel
like it's hurting the show but when
because last week well 17 days in a row
by the time I get I'm like dude we just
need a little bit of a rest I thought
that was the right call it was cuz I got
home last thing I'm tired is the worst
podcast we've ever had yep I don't want
that happening I've woken up on fire too
I know if I'm tired to get [ __ ] product
yeah
now we're fresh fresh fresh fresh down
daisies even though you made fun of my
shirt this is terrible shirt yeah you
know I'm at this shirt no I got that in
my car maybe I'll you know I'm gonna
switch house comes on Wednesday
Wednesday my car I'd kill myself as Ken
and Ryu drops of that you know you gone
this week yeah
where you going this time back to New
Orleans good news is this not going to
China how's that sound
not going to China all I got two more
days on the show shooting yeah this week
leave tomorrow a lot of work and then
it's morrow with time 1 1 p.m.
can we do the podcast Blair I sure talk
about that and then I got I leave
tomorrow and then next week and then I'm
done you know I was worried about China
that's a long flight and a long time
trying to say and you know why I'm not
doing China because the Chinese
government I play a cop in this I play a
special agent the Chinese government
basically said if you're not you will
not get distribution or the people that
were financing and said you will not get
distribution from the check from the
Chinese government if you show an
American agent special agent doing
police work on Chinese soil arresting
Chinese nationals that's yeah why not
because it wouldn't be much our to rush
out the idea would be that your guess
those here though it might have been in
Taiwan or something but the idea would
be that you're that the Chinese can't
taking her that yeah that with with that
the Americans to come on that would be
very very interesting it's really
interesting that was good news you'll
have to go to China yeah it's good news
how about this then we have to all due
respect to China but I know an actress
who could have said that she said bring
a filter for your water I go what do you
mean she goes the heavy metals in the
water and I was she was in Shanghai or
something and said they are Beijing he
said the heavy metals in the water
burned her face so that the makeup it
was a problem like there's something in
though in the shower that there was a
chemicals and stuff that [ __ ] her face
up really yeah you'd know her too it was
pretty crazy I was like what maybe it
was an isolated incident but I've heard
that the water is blood pollution there
a lot of pollution do you know I've
gotten balls deep bone is that hunting
Hitler Tim Kennedy yeah so what do you
where have you come out with it
is there a chance he could have yeah
well do you know Tim like never told a
lie in his life he's goddamn Boy Scout
involved Boy Scouts and Brogan asked him
on the podcast goes all seriousness you
think we have Hitler's body and Tim goes
after doing this research him for three
years I'd say no he goes he would hide
in Argentina or Chile so he took that
the store the historical story is that
in the bunker he and Eva Braun his
girlfriend took poison took cyanide and
then then a Nazi guy burned their bodies
right well they took cyanide but then
Hitler gunshot wound to the head right
yes I think he shot he shot himself yeah
her shot her shot himself then the then
the Nazis took the body burned it and
then they said they got rid of it right
so no one could do anything which is
weird right why would you burn the body
maybe and they're saying that that's not
real now and now with the when you watch
hunting Hitler and Tim and these experts
go through it there's so many there's so
many witnesses that saw Hitler and
there's also CIA and FBI documents
hundreds of documents that have Hitler
in Argentina and Chile after the war
yeah like certified FBI documents Wow
they go there's reason to believe this
is there were a lot of Nazis that went
to Argentina hundreds of thousands yeah
and to like Tim I show up into a country
there or a city and it's all German
there's like a lick of Spanish yes zero
zero Spanish and there they look down
upon the the locals and everything like
that and it's very strange
I did see with a guy who was from
Argentina but he was a giant aryan
german kid yeah it was crazy I was like
you're from ours and he spoke he spoke
Spanish but he was German this stuff is
fascinating to me I'm super balls deep
into it right now
Hitler in Tioga vegetarian that's it I
was just gonna say you know my most
favorite I will famous for the wrong
reasons but most famous vegetarian of
all time Hitler Hitler yeah and you know
he loved animals loved animals dog
sociopaths loved animals and apparently
quote unquote children even though he
killed you know countless numbers of
them you know as long as they're Aryan
children of horrible stories yeah crazy
though chin uh the Korean barbecue this
weekend they just chilled out what do
you watch on TV do you have a TV I don't
have a TV I just ordered one that he's
saying you're the one you're the one
which we
talk about your doing Jason yeah Jason
sent me a bunch of em so I got one of
those yeah a TCL I told you we recover
it for a housewarming gift you guys do
too much for me already it's important
entire existence
I'm just a man bro you're singing though
[ __ ] good man thanks dude yeah I
heard a song there damn it to send it to
you it cuz I want you to cover it is a
country yes really and it's right up
your alley sit over all the time send it
over I know [ __ ] why didn't I do that
what was that song you're saying it's
almost home by Craig Morgan can you play
it for us I want to know when you're
gonna sing an original song of yours I
think I will
pretty soon good that's important I like
it you should be doing that thanks man
for real in fact I think she'd cut an
album and we'll promote it the chin
album called the right 12 tracks jinx
you have so much time caught Bryan
caught Bryan Callen you play that chin I
let me see the one you just did the one
that I did yeah we hear the other one
you do the one you did how do you decide
what songs you sing this one was funny
no girls are sliding here dm's after
dropping this [ __ ] I do green angels
I do get dams nowadays like chicks right
yeah yeah you do anything about it her I
feel nothing already killing over
because they don't have dicks
oh my go to this hit it now what do you
always have to be barefoot you feel
better barefoot you know what's weird
about that
I don't even prepare it's just if I'm a
five socks on that day then I'll do it
with socks I don't know you know what
either barefoot or shoes not socks
yeah don't wear slippers or something
right uh no bare footed shoes hit it so
you were saying that microphone is the
first like real expensive microphone
ever purchased I haven't used it for
like four years I think it is like 14
2014 I are you bringing it back out so I
brought it back out and I just put on a
story like if you have any requests and
then a bunch of people just started
requesting I was like what the Oh
awesome that's so low do we take student
when you do it
go concert which in
he had plastic pads wrapped on his shoes
he was covered with Heyman news that a
terrible sauce Mars hands will put you
though the base fashion
it was freezing rains pedis pony was
curled up
large cans
I was a PHA that he was dedicating a
gentle shake but when he opened up his
house I said on
[Music]
[Music]
I got caught by those beats
[ __ ] good boy stur grateful Ajith
this voice just keep doing this and keep
their songs and start writing your own
write songs songs yeah that people go
that's really [ __ ] good then all of a
sudden you're like oh thanks
then somebody buys it I don't even care
about that though you quit know anything
you don't drop an album tour around and
get [ __ ] bro hey not to sir it's
about the art
yeah I'm trying to paint the life worm
you don't be like the k-pax man we're
like okay pass k-pop k-pop guys nah dude
if I did anything I just do like YouTube
videos just to do it oh you don't want
to do unplug to find the kid one night
with chin if you guys ever know one day
you and I do a dance behind it huh in
black silhouette ah because really here
know we're Cowboys dad no no no no I'll
be no will be dressed as Cowboys in the
back I'll play the cowbell yeah play it
see I think that'd be a distraction for
chili that would be freaking awesome
yeah after the whole song it's too much
it'd be too much for three minutes
that's a really good move when you do
interpretive dance cover your own face
and then me and then I'm holding up I'm
spinning
yeah he's flying yes yes here and then
you're not wearing pants and then we
both end on just chin we're just yep
and I tie I tie your three-piece set
really tight at the base or like I'm a
bull
yeah I really wrap it and just you see
oh yeah if you see just your balls or
you're riding in balls that's the
[ __ ] move what you I'm a boy I'm a
buck yeah take my three-piece set and
cinch it up behind you look so yeah sure
picking right out however you want to do
it so you're writing your have you seen
that I'm trying to gallop you off yeah
blue clouds yeah yeah yeah I got a
riding crop and I'm whipping them yes
out of your whole ass and you're so red
yes I'm whipping you stupid ass and
again I know I'm gonna take a rope I'm
gonna wrap it around the base your dong
yes okay fan out now you're and we're
gonna wrap it until I make you battle
your till your balls in your the end of
your dong we're only showing in there
horrible they're they're being spraying
hole say they're being strangled I
yanked that right up and I don't behind
right between your eyes and then sitting
in your cracker-ass
guys you're on your hands and knees and
I got a new [ __ ] no I'm not doing that I
got the rope over my shoulder as I'm
riding you and I'm like let's go you
[ __ ] donkey but you got a bread plaid
shirt on it's like but I wasn't gonna
happen with my psoriasis a-blazing I'm
just a red spot oh boy
I'm out let red spot it it's called red
spotted leopard boy in the balls nope
I'm out it's called red spotted leopard
boy and not and the donkey and the
cinched up donkey no you gotta be in
flawed outlaw come on you [ __ ] donkey
I gotta ruin the moment for kid and he's
singing
that's good I've on card that's that's
that's good modern art that's
interpretive art right I don't pass out
oh you're gonna pass out cinch up my
ball that pain is gonna be terrible and
you pass out yep oh no you farted - and
then chin the whole act is [ __ ]
yep no I think it's better if we're in
the back just as cowboys playing cowbell
and you're on the harmonica
alright you're crooked teeth [ __ ]
Invisalign
forgot him today things things nice
today hey tell me the truth did they
offer you one on one with two and then
he came in with those teeth and they
turned it down
they pulled the wrong yeah I [ __ ] do
it man I knew it was gonna catch up with
you eventually I did they're like no not
with those chompers [ __ ] knew it
did you watch the fights acting went
being shouldn't hear your perspective I
said listen to show on Monday [ __ ] yeah
I didn't say that but I've said too
cautious ah
no tell me what you thought tribesmen I
thought that I mean from what I've seen
of Darren till he's a he's a pressure
fighter but he tries to cut the ring off
uses his size really well and one of
boys a counter-puncher and I thought
they were very respected with each other
but but it was like nobody wanted to
pull the trigger I don't know I thought
it was a boring fight in that sense I
thought I was too cautious I thought
it's a boring front they were cautious
the the problem I thought there until
won the fight I'll take you to one star
you Steven Thompson well you gotta go to
Darren's Hill cuz he hit him he knocked
him down with a legit punch yeah yeah
but the other thing is too is you know I
I thought Darren till you know so
solidified himself is you know the
number one welterweight up-and-comer
superstar I mean you beat the number one
guy in the world yep in five rounds for
25 minutes
wonderboy is not an easy and he makes
everyone I think though that wonderful I
put his hands on till face more no and
come strike numbers would say deficit
restoring numbers because I think huh it
felt like I give the fight there until
because that knocked down but I did feel
like Tom wonderboy hit him in the face
more didn't he did not he did not so the
only thing you can if you're if you're a
Wonder Boy fan you could say well he'll
and more meaningful strikes but then if
we got a significant strikes that's not
there you could say he did a better job
avoiding the fight and then would circle
back and would do some damage I guess I
I don't see a lot of arguments for
Thompson even though some of the the
most respected experts was gave it to
Thompson I don't see it in the least you
got to give it to tell because it was so
we'd be in the minority hope but
wouldn't wait but you went till knocked
him down like that but that's the only
one that beat when talk about tonight
round when Thompson took him down and he
got right back up his that counts to
take down no it doesn't okay
god no um yeah so so yes I think there
until but to put the way this work so
the comedy strike numbers were in that
high level of a striking fight are so
close and no one is really sticking out
when it comes to that so let's take that
out so that judging criteria we can't
that's what they base it off first right
if you're a judge you look at who's
winning the fight based off who's that
in the most strikes the most damaging
strikes and that's how you judge a fight
so that's out so close they don't have
the eye for it no one really does so
it's gonna be tough so then what's the
next criteria octagon control
aggressiveness yes who would you give
that to tell I have two and then if you
and then if you alright will like you
thought
then which maybe some people did ago
well wonder boil and more ok well let's
leave the time strike numbers okay
didn't do that either right okay so
weird again I think people I agreed him
died and I said this on below the belt I
think people had expectations on dare
until that he was gonna go in there he
was in a fight reckless and hopefully
get the knockout but if not wonder boys
can knock him out and he's guaranteed a
second round knockout when that didn't
happen and he fought smart calculated
for 25 minutes people are upset now yeah
smart or cautious and I thought flat
smart I thought one boy fought cautious
like he always does yeah but I thought
wonder boy
I thought sorry I thought till fought
smart I thought he could open up a
little more but when you're winning the
exchanges which he was and he's
dominating out gun control and if we
would have known going into the fifth
round here he had it won he would Coast
the fifth round yeah he's already up on
the scorecards I thought 4 to 1 3 to 2
is fine too but I thought at least 3 to
2 so you know so when you he had to
fight one you know when you're fighting
wonderboy Thompson and it's you should
be more mad at wonder boyfriend critique
to fight his fighting style is what this
is what happens
fought with Woodley we've seen it before
you notice fight it was Maas Vidale
wasn't exactly excited out these two
fights Woodley weren't exactly exciting
it because because in order for him to
have exciting fight you have to go throw
caution the win and go forward yes but
if you're on tills level
and you have that level of striking
you're not gonna do that and he to me
what's so impressive he 24 25 minutes he
played Wonder Boys game and beat him yes
he and how you don't aren't just [ __ ]
ecstatic about that if you're a tail fan
UFC Fan I don't get it I do not get it
yeah I do not sometimes I don't get this
fan base we still yet to see what till
does against a guy who takes him down
and what he spent four years in Brazil
let's see what his what he does against
a good wrestler who gets on top of them
but but this is a story with everyone
we've done this with Conor we've done
that now with tills
before cowboy everyone had their
reservations including me I went well
he's really beating nobody book and then
fat cowboy cowboy ever look them he
stomped cop you know key beat cowboy I
figure much bigger yeah that's what
everyone said and then you know wonder
Boyd number one in the world he's beat
Roy McDonald he had the draw with wood
leaves meet miles of ethology but you
know Johny Hendricks
he's be different right yeah so then
everyone goes how good is till uh he's
so good he went 25 minutes yes with the
number one guy in the world
and be better that's how [ __ ] good he
is I don't get it I got I got a question
for you what Bryan how does he do
against I'd like to see him fight Jorge
Masvidal
no more than I would like to see him
fight nope you ready hold on ready get
your teeth on your teeth or north on
ready hold your [ __ ] teeth too long
to suck on this a Robbie Lawler who's
number three in the world Robbie Lawler
Derek Hill do you hate money UFC do you
hate superstardom because Darren tells
your next rocket ship he's your net and
now Bisping's retired now I need the
face of England he's it man he's a huge
drawing liver probably lower robbie
lawler dare until however will be still
in is he injured
is he no peace i well he's training
knives back training but he'll wait in
fight the winner of kobe Cummington rd a
in june so whole fight i would imagine
he thought maybe august a little later
baby october okay
i saw mills get to us fight one more has
to be a big name then he'll get touched
okay I did see I did see Wonder Boy shot
that double leg took him down
couldn't couldn't hold him down but I I
kind of went oh
hoping for a double leg oh no you they
see that doesn't work so mm a math
doesn't work because when you're
fighting Wonder Boy you wanna know how
much wrestling he did you ready just
asked me which one won in that fight do
you think any of them worked wrestling
at all no there have to be zero
so when you're fighting Woodley yeah
that's all you're gonna be doing
striking we got covered so you look at
the whole camps can be defending a
takedown set up your knee strikes and
elbows right so when you shock it and
that also shows you I think that Wonder
Boy is losing the fight I mean the last
time cuz you one last thing he was
thinking he wasn't planning on it he
wasn't even thinking about it so okay
it's [ __ ] in Taekwondo yeah you when
Wonder Boy shoots a dub like you if I
would have told you hey in the what
round was four enough in the fourth in
the fourth the fifth round Wonder Boys
gonna shoot a double who's way in the
fight every person knows i went till
must be whooping his ass yeah if he
hears your [ __ ] sign that till won
the fight
one boy shot a double leg cuz he's
getting out struck yeah
I want to see the stupid [ __ ]
question I want to see a fight a good
wrestler we'll see that's how it goes
yeah everyone that this is MMA well who
knows man uh he beat the number one guy
in the world so crazy that's great
craziness yeah he's a beast monster he's
so big but dead that but that's the
world we live in in sight your father
see everyone not me too I'm like man
what how many fight but he just beat the
number one striker in the world then um
one ranked welterweight in the world
yeah can people go ah but man let's see
him fight this guy do we beat Tim yeah
watches fights this guy [ __ ] beat his
fights before it's were nothing to blow
your hair back so that's why everyone's
so surprised tell a killer he's you know
but that's the world we live in
everyone's alright by the way he's 24 25
yeah
still a young man so what do you think
happens when he fights
Tyron Woodley I think he's our dad tough
he is he has the skills to beat Woodley
well he's a tough [ __ ] guy to beat
well he's a great champion he's gonna be
tough to get out of there I will say
this though it's better for the division
for Woodley to lose the turnover it's
great
yeah the turnover right now 170 there's
so many monsters
good yeah what about what about Robbie
Lawler what about him well fight and
fight until it's a great fight I'd take
till you take - yeah just him curdling
how about til there what he's Robbie
Lawler a different fighter now than he
was before he fought Rory MacDonald uh
well of course
yeah he's older yeah thought about
retirement of course yeah it's a perfect
fight for tail by the way why don't you
get Jim you had some in some tournaments
yes I do first one is Roseanne Barr and
her Twitter rant that was racist got her
fired or actually canceled the show
Roseanne you see on ABC the biggest show
on in America huge numbers which is so
far as de freitas 40 million they fired
her within minutes yeah within minutes
they fired her
I mean you know cops or she just a
[ __ ] idiot
I think it's gotta be self-sabotage they
she's always had this she said like
controversial stuff before and then her
and Donald Trump are two peas in the pod
this conspiracy stuff you know and
Muslim Brotherhood and plan of the Apes
had a baby equals Valerie Jarrett
Valerie Jarrett is of Iranian descent as
she has I think she's Muslim her
father's in African America and her
grandfather so you know and and so this
is why why why did she get that out they
mean why did she tweet out you know
she's an [ __ ] she always has been now
think about this so yeah I've heard that
right and you know Whitney Cummings quit
the show a few weeks ago yeah cuz she
butted heads with if you do that if you
did it it's one thing like to be
political as though there's nothing to
criticize somebody's so Muslim
Brotherhood in Planet Apes had a baby
equals Valerie like like like um to me
if you're that vicious about some of
these looks and you're comparing them to
an ape and stuff hold on girl you don't
think I'll write their chin sorry keep
going B you don't think you don't think
there's gonna be blowback in this
environment so she sends out in them she
deletes it in response i positive a
leader in to all Americans I'm truly
sorry for making a bad joke about her
all takes and her looks I should have
known better forgive me my joke was in
bad taste and then NBC went nada or ABC
went nope cancelled see ya
so she said it was a joke tweet no she's
covering Raska Sawin oh [ __ ] you
definitely should have put that like
like you know I mean you're just being
an [ __ ] man and she means Lauren also
make comms on Twitter Tuesday about
Chelsea Clinton tweeting Chelsea sorrows
Clinton she'll a replied in the comments
that Clinton is married to Starr his
nephew sorry it's not true being a
liberal benefactor alright but like you
know made but also but also just [ __ ]
do comedy a comedy sitcom yeah like we
don't need I hate to tell you no one's
tune into Roseanne Barr any community to
take this or entertainer
no one is tuning in to hear your
political opinion that's not why I'm
gonna put why but that's not why your
social media is not intended it's also
not a political opinion it's just a mean
thing to [ __ ] say you know me I give
people I try to give you all the benefit
of the doubt like I you criticize me for
it but I can't I get in this case it's
like you're just being an [ __ ] man
Chelsea Clinton responded get more in
Roseanne my given mail a name is
viktoria I imagine George sorrows
nephews are lovely people
I'm just not married to one yeah I'm
grateful for the important work does in
the world have a great day and then at
ABC how desperate are you to profit from
Rosen's racism we know racism cells in
this country
it always has but you don't have to
participate in it the apologies
meaningless cancel Roseanne because
people are asking them to cancel it hold
on viewership was so big that even
President Trump praised debut of course
saying over 18 million people and it was
about us the president also called bar
after premier to congratulate her
jeez I wonder where she is now with big
stars English stars when they sign out
and do a show the question is now what
in their contract
what's gonna say in their country this
is a disaster right so now in their
contract
what is that contract and it's a video
to conduct yeah but here's the thing
don't be racist well we have to put down
the contract so be racist we can't hire
you if you're raised
we can't do that also don't use your
Schultz from if you are racist
look I don't use your social media for
yourself once you keep it under wraps
but also Obama said it best there's no
need to call out racist they're gonna
show it over time boom cancel biggest
show if you're ABC it's the right thing
to do and now
Roseanne you can't touch she's done done
you can't touch she's always been a
nightmare she's always come with baggage
it's always been like ah boy you know
there's always been issues with her but
I didn't know she was you know it's like
it's one thing to be self-destructive
it's not that which I think this is
self-destructive but I just I just think
she's a racist bigot and she's that way
and she doesn't know any better and she
was like nope that's how I am and it's
Roseanne Barr and we'll be fine well no
well no oh you have the biggest show and
you think that's all that matters
well something you understand is when
you're racist like this is those
advertisers on the show which that's all
the bottom line cares about is money
they can't work with the show anymore so
they pulled the numbers down so then now
what now that of course ABC's like get
the [ __ ] out it not to mention the head
of ABC is african-american is that right
yes oh
african-american what are you doing yeah
you [ __ ] yeah now here's the other
thing I think about see how many people
work on that show I think how hard is to
get a number one show on a sitcom this
day and age on a major network theame
people bent over backwards to make this
show happen and because your selfish ass
tweets this [ __ ] out they're out of
a job
of course John Goodman be fine but sing
about everybody else look this out for a
sec before I said keep calm I'm
listening to you so you also said that
Wanda Sykes one of Sykes quit minutes
after she tweeted this yep
ABC is Disney home I don't know how
about Roseanne goes sorry and not
because you know people are like what
the [ __ ] are you doing man and then like
you know you show canceled and that you
know she's thought she's untouchable
it's just it's unbelievable man it's
unbelievable how stupid she is
yeah and how it affects everyone else on
the show and I didn't know I didn't know
Whitney Cummings I just found out
recently that she do you talk to her
about I have this article
so it says Roseanne's Co showrunner
Whitney Cummings leaves reboot I think
she she said it was because of schedule
and everything else but the rumors were
that she didn't like the direction of
where I was going
the politics everything oh yeah I highly
doubt goes scheduling yeah she was a
huge part of mm-hmm interesting drama
[ __ ] yeah let some more on let's go to
the next current event we let me read
this email yet because week we start
talking about the yes so we start
talking about the NFL Neely we start on
the NFL that the the kneeling how Roger
Goodell made a rule now that you have to
stay in the locker room otherwise we
don't see it and you'd be penalized
stuff like that and so when Brian West
and I comment on this it's up we only
know one perspective and it's from a
white privilege Caucasian male side
right right like from our tweet I can't
I can't do Freaky Friday and jump in an
African Americans body so I don't know
I'm coming from my side from my
surroundings sure which probably isn't
the baddest fair it's not probably the
best narrative on this and part of some
other narrative unless you have it this
one's a little yeah this one's a little
long but I'll try to summarize it so
this guy I won't say his name pregnant
his name out there but his name's
Darnell will de leave that that
african-american man good morning
actually hate them about to be one of
those people who we get emails all the
time so don't feel bad about this I
actually hate that I'm about to be the
one of those people who write in about a
show I never have I normally never would
because I have too much time my hands
that being said after your latest show I
feel compelled offer a different
perspective on the episodes the
conversation around the NFL players
taking a knee as a black man in America
hearing three Caucasian men discussed
the change in rules for the ants anthem
was interesting in a bit disappointing
I'm a huge fan of what both of you do
hash tag Brian's teeth drive me crazy as
well I'm she can I put that in myself
I've come to shows bought merch induce
others of podcasts you don't have to
listen to me however you
understand where I'm coming from I agree
that the NFL players are employees and
prior to the rule changed they weren't
in violation of any rule or conduct code
of conduct I like many other black
people in this country was happy to see
athletes take such a stand
I grew up constantly hearing sports
pundits and average Joes complaining
that athletes didn't use their platform
enough to see Colin Kaepernick and Eric
Reid start this movement was inspiring
for people like me so often athletes
keep away from hot-button issues because
they know that owners are current
potential sponsors will possibly no
longer do business with them via Colin
Kaepernick they made a sacrifice in a
large segment of white America took
offense it was turned to patriotism
issue and patriotism issue and the media
has tried to make it seem as though
these gentlemen were going up against
the military which is far from the truth
from day one that had nothing to do with
the military this is a false narrative
this had to do with black people being
treated as second-class citizens in a
country that we have helped build Colin
Colin Kaepernick actually sat down with
a member of the Armed Forces and after
individual suggested that he could kneel
instead of sit he sufficed America has
had a long history of trying to silence
black voices whether it was not being
allowed to vote or being kept out of
certain occupations President Trump also
weighed in after this change was made
and said they should stand and if they
don't like it maybe they should leave
the country he was well the problem with
this this is close to saying go back to
Africa as you can get a man who's the
leader of the free world took the time I
was day to tweet about sports you know
it took him a day or two to even address
the acts of violence of Virginia
when white supremacists hit the armed
streets to the teeth please know I love
this country it's armed to the teeth
this protest is about want to be oh this
protests about wanting to be seen as in
treat as equals not be an anti-american
so please hear me out and think about
next time before you speak those are
valid points that I think we all agree
on both of you I think we were just
talking about the fact that when you
work for any corporation there's a
certain code of conduct that you kind of
have a and if the if what you're doing
is affecting their bottom line you have
to contend with that I think that's what
we're talking about so I agree with what
understand that perspective yeah I think
you and I were talking about business
it's not about bottom line and and and
where where if if you kneel and you are
an employee of that company and it's
hurting the employee company's bottom
line that is a conversation we had and
so that company which is a NFL is a
private company I mean it's an
organization but I mean the teams are
private right a private yeah if if it's
actually hurting profits and viewership
then then I would imagine that that
company has a responsibility or a right
or or it's in there whatever
jurisdiction or their decision to make
that choice now you can protest that
choice - okay which is part of what
having three speeches but I think that's
we're talking about is the fact that any
time you work for any corporation let
well like me we get Brian suit
Brian what a [ __ ] super blow tailoring
my act you know and I don't like it but
you're gonna keep doing you know so this
is a tough issue it's an American issue
and it's a tough issue and I hear what
he's saying
but I agree with them the fact of the
matter is that that is that is the case
anytime you work for a private
organization you're going to have to to
an extent I would tell it that would you
just shut the mouth when they don't
agree with something that's it but
that's and it's their only play here's
what I think you can do you can still
Neil you can you can not show up you can
do whatever you want
that's what decision be dance for
consequences and and and I think that
anytime you do anything in life they're
gonna be consequences or there's gonna
be a fight because they're gonna people
on the other side who oppose that
decision for a lot of reasons I think
the problem you just know that you're
gonna just know that in this country
when you do that there's with your back
white there's gonna be repercussions I
have to stand a fight for yeah but I
think for them to like at first it was
about kneeling because they didn't like
the treatment with cops and black people
and how they're getting treated same
class citizens and the media made about
all their anti-american Milot about
point which is super and they're like
they're so we're not saying yes in Colin
Kaepernick even met with a soldier
maybe seal some [ __ ] like that and he
goes dude taking me that's the way you
don't disrespect red flag and he's and
then he did that yeah and even then
they're like Oh anti-american you're
disobeying the flag and it's not fair to
that in this country Americans are so
nationalistic anytime you do anything if
you're a country music star and you
criticize the president you will see oh
you'll see yeah you will see your your
sales go down so people artists athletes
whoever it is Muhammad Ali I mean we
always forget Muhammad Ali this is
different it's a very very very hard
time especially France Americans
completely in the height at the top of
his career refused to go to Vietnam and
was called a draft dodger it was called
a traitor was called a Muslim trader I
mean all the things you can think of and
lost his boxing license for six years in
this prime in his prime yeah six years
and talk about moral courage so but
don't tell how do we not learn from that
we have a history maybe it's a [ __ ]
history how do not learn from that
Americans it's crazy but then Roseanne
sends out a racist tweet and then they
cancel our show right you know I'm
saying so it's like we have zero
tolerance for racism but then when these
African American athletes are trying to
do something to enhance the eyeballs on
what they're going through in this
nation yeah I can't do that though well
you can't do it but you're gonna pay
there's there's a fine we can't do it by
not coming out well now you can't do it
by you know there you can do it it's a
question of you can't do on the field
name yeah let Jim and that's that's
that's gonna be always a controversial
issue burning a flag in the 90s when
people were burnin flags and I was at
working at Lehman Brothers and all the
guys I was there with we're like alright
you have a right to burn your flag that
I have a right to attack you and I was
like all right guys I know but the flag
stands for the fact that you can burn
the flag but Americans lift the [ __ ]
flags a little different or bush senior
went and toured an American flag factory
and said I have such a great feeling
I don't think she'd be on so it's it's
always gonna be a very controversial
issue and yoshio Jim
debates important
okay this is in France gentlemen who is
actually undocumented ma illegal AMP
illegal immigrant was there for I think
six months ended up seeing a baby
dangling from a patio all the way up
yeah this is rise to be many many floors
up house stuck I think there was four
year old not being watched that's
exactly not being watched found it got
over the railing and somehow thank God
got stole my god it's a nightmare and
this bad [ __ ] you see how he
does this is watch out watch how this
dude have you seen that's the baby
dangling yes he sees it and he just
starts climbing like are those all those
people screaming yeah Brennan look at
how he's jumping up though and catch
yeah he climbs is ridiculous watch for
sure he's gonna jump and catch for sure
maybe move over he misses it's game over
for him look at this dumbass wipers
trying to climb if somebody up there
right now yeah but there's like a
barrier he can't get past so you try to
just hold him there
this guy just times over an odd bird
oops just reasonable christ almighty
so he's a hero and since he's
undocumented good can mayor the mayor
that of the city and the president
michael they're gonna give him [ __ ]
that's so they're offering him a job as
a like a fire fireman dude that's so
cool what a great story
My Fair is the half a step for the guy I
literally got it I think we got it sir
who this guy he sees him going is a good
idea brother then look where is it you
see him oh this I think we got it man
struggle city to look at this
he's this guy has like crazy athleticism
right guys yes yeah that's amazing man
it's very hard to do mmm that's so cool
what else you got Jim let's see what
else there is not all heroes wear camo
he's very poor hungry Oh since this guy
was a guest of the show a friend of the
show big J so Kevin Smith he's gonna do
another Jay and Silent Bob reboot and
they're filming this summer they have
like a huge die hard life they have a
cult following us stuff you know I've
never seen them you know saw the movies
no I've never been a fan I know B he
does great movies I just
I know I've never seen him he's a mean
one one of my favorite guests of all
time on there one of my ladies amazing
how's he doing I wonder he had that
heart attack and then his he came out on
Showtime he's probably doing well like
he's exercising he's like vegan right
now he long they're kind of way good
yeah he looks really good and then you
know II can't show you she shot I think
three shows were special and after the
second one Ian's heart attack scary I
didn't see you special but it was on
Showtime and I know it went well for him
but he's one my favorite guest on her
awesome I'm sure their fans are crunk I
know that Silent Bob does he does like
he done do stand-up but use it San Jose
in profit for me the guy that plays Jay
Jay yeah yeah sorry Jay does use you
don't do stand-up but he does like live
shows we just Q&A and stuff like that
just yet San Jose improv after me
sweet huge fallin right those guys yeah
those the cult following B's you've seen
it be yeah you love them Clarkson movies
well back then this is when when when I
independent film could change your whole
career in life no longer doesn't exist
any yeah but what else you guys to check
these monkeys oh not this one this one
so this is in India and there's these
monkeys that are just attacking people
in a really messed-up way I wanna show
you right now this is in India in India
oh [ __ ] hold on see what he just runs
and just tackles him and then they book
it and then they just hurt people and
take off her people take off and this
one just bounces that's how why do they
do this that happened to me I'll tell
you really yep
I'll tell you story this one you can see
why the monkeys cook this Chris guys
kind of like you know sort of harassing
him oh [ __ ] dude I'll be honest with you
that guy deserved animals I'll punch
that monkey [ __ ] face I'm afraid I
serve a warrant justice backpack is the
old grandma boom [ __ ] dude
for no reason to hit these monkeys are
just jerks dude they're bullies look at
you dude and that was the harassing that
guys out there with a [ __ ] stick
let's see what you do do yeah I can do
shy well it makes me mad yeah
me monkey I'll punch you in the face
monkey you have no idea what seeing I'll
go out I'll go do that right now you
want it hey I get don't um
now I don't know why but I'm pissed off
hey kids you see what happens when you
hire trainer to teach you box and you
think you can fight oh there you go
there you go they hit you from behind so
I'm in Indonesia
I'm studying or Angleton's I mean hello
rang Tang story which is this weird
ghost of the given monkey place its name
and I'm walking on this dock then I'm
walking through this sort of clearing
with their trees on all sides see that
thing it's Nate tonight okay is any yeah
it's a gig what's a monkey bro no it's a
given it's the smallest ape small estate
and family no tail now no tail now I
their percent make beautiful noises at
night that let's say you listen bring up
the sound a Gibbon makes it's quite
beautiful scrotum was like giant yep
sounds like a debt to male it sounds
like a giant dove they're beautiful like
a dove so listen this hear it I was like
an elk right we got long fingers our
look his arms along oh yeah
and that's all you hear when they're in
the area and they were everywhere damn
yeah I would say it's beautiful
it sound like a giant bird so anyway I'm
listening and I'm like that and I'm
walking and I should fade I fed I helped
feed the orangutans up with pineapple
yeah I cut the pineapple up you go here
you go here you go here you go
yep they don't even apply now I'm
walking did it do to do go back have
some rice maybe some little fish paste
sure delicious and I don't know where a
Gibbon jumps on my [ __ ] head jumps on
my hand right here break the [ __ ] out
he's out right [ __ ] you can't grab them
just cuz I thought something horrible it
happened to me I thought a leper did
fall because they have like [ __ ] yeah
tree leopard some [ __ ] I [ __ ] flip
out the thing jumps back up the wazoo
years like they're all screams at me I'm
like I run away they're like oh yeah
he's very mischievous why do they do
that his name was like this was like
just bored a Shan or something hammer
pens name is Brendon okay and a Pam I
don't know it was a guy was it paying it
was a male he was an adolescent cell are
you saying Pam alright I was I don't
remember his name but for the story his
name is Pam Johnny okay um
it's scared I wonder why they do that
though what month I just do that to that
old lahee the old lady broke her face
yeah she's probably at stott that that's
like that's some monkey figured that out
and the other monkey's are copying him
monkeys are [ __ ] sometimes and it
takes one like so they've done these
studies these fascinating studies with
the Robert Sapolsky who's an
evolutionary virus with baboons when you
have male baboons
that are mean like certain male baboons
are like they become really mean so it
becomes like the biggest toughest guy
ruled the roost everybody's all quiet
and it's like really [ __ ] up he flee
he gets all the women he beats up on the
guys and then there was a they eat first
those monkeys so there was a
tuberculosis outbreak
where they they the the big bad monkeys
get all the food and they hog it and
they all the other ones were hungry like
[ __ ] you get out of here and they ate
all the food that food for what a reason
that was tubercular so they got
tuberculosis and they all died so all
the means big powerful monkeys died so
then in the baboon troop the ones that
weren't mean the beta males kind of like
took over and they were like cooperative
and stuff and the whole [ __ ] consume
the whole troop was just better off
really right yeah the sex
oh and healthier lived longer oh wow
totally totally amazing cuz they even go
the other way
cuz that mean the big mean tyrants were
gone oh wow yeah
and it was really well they like suffer
no we got food no no one's getting do
operative Oh more sacks spread out
evenly
I make sense more genetic diversity you
mean doesn't work and mean doesn't work
Brendan don't be an alpha baboon and
don't be a bully and more importantly
don't make fun of people's appearances I
think we've learned if I'm really lucky
shirt well what else you got my teeth
cancel Brendan shut mm-hmm look at his
face yep that's Donald Trump and
remember he was talking about pardoning
Jack Johnson it actually happened and
there's a ceremony and my voice yeah how
cool that dude you know you can get that
all that removed from underneath his
eyes
there's Lennox Lewis semester so that
makes sense
although semester call him this way that
he that's why they're doing that why
wait let's not go through he has no idea
who he is
this is 42:39 knockouts could I take him
in a fight if I really went to work you
ought to get past those long arms
we also zinging worse than this cheap
talk you'd have to buy those Walmart's
Jack Johnson the answer is Leonard that
actual assistant if I trained you you
would tough life and an interesting life
one of the greatest fighters Lennox was
just telling me one of the greatest
fighters his eyes are distracting you've
seen those goldfish with the fat bags
under their eyes yeah yeah it's
interesting this sure is amazing look at
that hair the eyes man I didn't notice
the puffy I thought was just the white
coloring no it's nothing huge nuts under
your eyes it's a condition can get it
removed yeah tough life they say he
violated the Mann Act and he had a
conviction that occurred during a period
of tremendous racial mrs. Barrington yes
it is anyhow he was actually pardoned
posthumously cool I took a hundred just
in time I'm sure Jack's thrilled can we
go look and I look at somebody strong
one more time please and he looks
they're both him and Trump look like wax
statues that's gotta give it up though
look he's trim he looks like a knife in
a suit look at him eyebrows a very high
fan of semesters long you got to be a
fan he's awesome
I mean come on yeah well this hair but I
love the man he's he's better than mine
and yours oh yeah way better
he has he's the way he no I think he
just takes care of himself
goddamn in the nth degree now do you
think he does all they cheat you think
that's just official I don't know what
you're talking about
well he's been caught in Australia and
by the way Lennox is looking very thin
he looks lighted small right small it
looks like he's like muscles like he's
lost a lot of weight yeah look at Deonte
yeah it was cool to see Deonte Walter
there yeah he is very tall because Lenox
is huge oh yeah entertain six a free
young tanto really yeah huge Jesus
wonder what how he would have done
against Lennox great fight
great fight right Lennox [ __ ] one
all-time greats man
yeah anything fight legal old-school
phones it's an interesting picture well
what else you get Jim how many more you
want I don't know any other good ones oh
there's some nice ones like this one
were a teenager so this kid from Alabama
his bus driver actually took a picture
of thing it's gone there tell me tell me
this isn't sad no it's a great one
oh they ran over some [ __ ] Chandra dark
man this is all happy stuff so the bus
driver took a picture of this kid that
he walks I think it was like 9 an hour
no 90-mile it was it let me see a kid
walks no sorry ok big difference walks
14 miles to get to school T miles I had
all this memory hold on says you tell me
this ain't determination he got on my
bus to go to his graduation no one was
with him I picked him up in eating
projects drop him at the cross Plex in
five points sometimes it's all in what
you want out of life he didn't have on
the best he didn't have on the best but
he was the best in my eyes I'm so proud
of this black young man so he wakes up
at 4:30 and walks all the way for as
long as still 541 to get on a bus to
then go to school yeah and then the not
the teacher the bus driver took a
picture of him with his you know his
gallon on and then a local radio station
found out about it and they bought him
of car wow this guy is so cool smiley so
even when he would get out of school he
couldn't get from that side of town
until 520 when the bus runs back over
there so he doesn't make it back this
way into about 6:30 7:00 he's up at 4:00
4:30 a.m. walks all the way to 540 what
a beast man I tell you what it's so cool
good for him hold on the recent grad has
reportedly been offered a full
scholarship Jacksonville University
that's so cool what's the major in
computer science he's received more than
eleven thousand dollars in donations
thanks to GoFundMe launched Bobbitt and
he bought a ton of Yeezys well are easy
to that you add that in no
and then it's so cool man yeah it is let
us use happy stories mmm how about this
so a pretty popular Southern Baptist
leader gave advice to someone who's
getting beaten up by her husband to stay
with him and pray for your husband
anyways he was removed from his post
after [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I have the audio here
I'd love to hear it that's him do not
forget the power of concentrated
concentrated prayer get on your face
before God and ask him to intervene and
he is a good and a dear Heavenly Father
and at some point he will intervene I
just give you one brief example of it I
had a woman who was in a church that I
served and she was being subject to some
abuse and I told her I said alright I
don't want you to do this every evening
I want you to go down but your bed just
as he goes to sleep get down by the bed
and when you think he's just about to
sleep you just pray and ask God to
intervene out loud quietly but I said
you just pray there and I said get ready
because he may get a little more violent
you know when you when he discovers this
and sure enough he did she came to
church one morning with both eyes black
and she was angry at me and at God in
the world for that matter and she said I
hope you are happy and I was just I am
and I said I'm sorry about that but I'm
very happy but a piece of she didn't
know when we sat down searched that
morning was that her husband had coming
in and was standing at the back the
first time he ever came and when I gave
the invitation that morning he was the
first one down but who gives the [ __ ]
heart was broken he said my watch
playing for me and I can't believe what
I did do and he said do you think God
could forgive somebody like me and he's
a great husband today and you know about
so he's talking about transformation
through prayer that's just a Christian
thing mm-hmm well he was relieved of his
that's what he says he said I'm happy
but then the catch is oh by the way he's
here and he's pretty me and he
you know Redemption and you know
forgiveness and now he's a great husband
but there's the real world so when
that's that's faith and that's prayer
that's faced by the same time you did
this happen to this year I know this is
uh mm mm I think okay still in the
modern world so when a woman comes up to
you goes hey man my husband's beating
the [ __ ] out of me I'll pray on it good
luck comes back goes he's beating me
even worse you go all good I'm happy
about what I know because that you go to
the police first of all if you're if
you're a spiritual practitioner your job
is to you can say go to the police but
I'm sure that's also a jurisdiction of
the police he's her spiritual guide and
counselor he's a Christian so the idea
is pray for him here's a story that
helped you know I mean this is the man
of faith
so so they don't want you to let things
that way but he's basically saying
forgiveness prayer all that stuff can be
helpful I think I think we can't just
chalk it up to faith I think you have to
be reasonable and like we should
probably get out but pray for well
whatever I gather advices I mean if you
to me it's like now and then when you
then what else is alarming means it's
happened before
now you might beat you even worse but
just keep praying for well that's it
that's that's not real that would be a
Christian thing though it's not real
though but it's it's an act of faith I
mean crimina Christ surprise a parade
doesn't mean it's right forgave and
prayed for the people that you know put
them on the cross that would be the idea
pray for your enemies that's their idea
but love your enemy that's a Christian
thing right yeah but also in in the real
world if a woman skin I want the real
world know we are gonna christen you
stopped abide by the rules he doesn't
what he's doing is does he not right no
no he's giving her advice as her
spiritual counsel there's no no law that
says I have to tell you ceasing cific
mouths the law he's rude you don't you
don't think it's fair for him to go keep
praying for him you and I might go talk
you might I might do that I'm not gonna
criticize him for saying his faith is it
is essentially pray pray pray love your
enemy turn the other cheek and pray for
and forgive your enemy
forget that's a Christian doctrine so
I'm not sure why when he was saying that
he lost his
job I don't get it you know I would
personally that's parsley and ice well
you might want to go to the police
yeah and report but this is domestic
violence is you know pretty common
unfortunately and complicated did also
all this stuff we saying that then it
sound like he's sort of just making up
that story because I don't like it made
up right to an extent everything's in
narrative and and and you get and just
because the story is made up in the
Bible or in a book or in a movie doesn't
mean it doesn't have power and doesn't
help you through a problem because it's
a metaphor for how to behave in the
world and every story is and if it's a
good story
the theme is the author's argument for
how you should behave in the world all
right so hold on so before we don't
think this guy's should been fired so he
let you advise a woman studying there
who said she had been raped by a fellow
student not to report it they shamed the
crap out of me asking me questions after
questions the woman who now works in
public relations that's very I didn't
see that but we're but where do we draw
the line with faith well first of all
first of all if the person raped you
okay well it's not his job and you were
shamed by them yeah but in the Bible I
got a Bible it's not his job to reap
that deplete you're just reading this
for the first time I'm responding to
what I heard this is very different see
I see I call no correlation between rape
and beating a woman to me as a man I
will give a [ __ ] Muslim Christian
Catholic you should not say just pray on
it hopefully he gets better right you
should you should definitely cuz you
know Christian and ather am I so what I
would do is I go but I have friends who
were balls-deep and Christian and he
would not say that yeah but what you
have heard you heard I'm responding to
what he said so we heard we just heard
the part of one phone call or one thing
right I don't know what else he said but
based on what he said just there where
he's just talking about being a
Christian and praying when he said he
can with Ray for your husband that's
what I heard you you think it but he
says you know what else he said we won't
say it's gonna get worse and just pray
for them to catch you praying it's gonna
get worse
meaning he's gonna beat you up even
worse just pray through it that's
Christian and you'll have a problem with
that well I what I'm saying is you're
saying he should lose his job over that
what I'm saying is that I don't know
what else he said and I'm saying that
I'm saying based off that being a
spiritual counselor when you say to
somebody you've gone through a really
hard time whatever it is
pray pray on it okay I'm not gonna fire
somebody for that you say no matter what
they did now you're you're criticizing
him for not giving him giving additional
advice not prepared to do that I'm not
gonna fire anybody for not giving the
advice you think should be given because
I Got News for You I got a lot of news
for you I have a friend who worked for a
long time with domestic violence who
continues to I should say and one of the
biggest hardest things is getting people
to take your advice including and
especially going to the police to the
point where though for she runs a and
I've done plenty of charities for this
she runs a an organization that provides
safe houses safe spaces for women and
generally yeah because what happens is
you want to leave because nothing yeah
I'll hunt you down yeah so it's it's
really scary and really dangerous and
it's got to be treated with it's very
very delicate because by the way a lot
of times and I don't have the stats but
when a woman tries to really leave
that's when she gets killed you know
it's very dangerous and her kids so so
this is an organization that provides
safe corner and anonymous where you can
take your children no questions asked
and show up at the shelter because when
you have a violent man you're living
under that violent man number one here's
another terrible fact for whatever
reason a lot of women that suffer from
domestic abuse well a lot of times
because of past trauma find a man
another area of the gravitate towards it
yeah so it becomes this habitual thing
so a large part of like counseling for
domestic abuse survivors that I from my
experience of talking to people to do it
is getting them to realize that they are
they themselves don't deserve more than
this and Shabab it shouldn't find
dangerous and I get to be it's
complicated I think but the world I love
not say this guy's piece of [ __ ] of
course well you and I agree so
for me because I don't believe in just
praying where I go as I go cool
yeah pray tonight though tonight he's
gonna black in my lip in my eyes and
from chillies or killing or you might
kill me if you catch me praying like you
said he might kill me I don't sure so if
I'm if I'm there dude I'm gonna go like
this I'm gonna go hey and you're gonna
be the same way
excuse me this is all awesome II go to
the police and record him on your phone
because he's a dangerous person and get
the [ __ ] out of there you know there are
a lot of reasons but a lot of times then
it gets even worse cuz they she got
raped by one of his [ __ ] prayer Bible
humpers and then shame the crap out of
me I had to bottle it up my husband
didn't know about it until last week I
told my I need to do something in two
days meaning deciding Peterson's fate
the seminars Board of Trustee said it
also affirmed emotions stating evidence
exists that dr. passion had compiled
with reporting laws regarding assault
and abuse someone stands against all
forms of abuse so he's a history of yes
he's [ __ ] applied with reporting laws
regarding I saw on the Beast and
remember also what's really interesting
about a lot of Christian you know
institutions is that marriage you stay
married
no matter losts divorce was illegal for
a long time force it was for the longest
was so friend you couldn't get your
divorce mom with the single kid yeah oh
my god and he's what says here she and
this kind of guy he is
she and thirty other women immediately
drafted open letters addressing the
Board of Trustees about the rape and
stuff like Oh 30 women yeah take a look
at them take a look at when the Catholic
Church or when a sort of recognized
divorce because I think divorce for a
long time was it was always like that
was last last restored no matter what
husband cheating on your husband beating
you never got just silly as [ __ ] it all
this is silly try try to try starting a
religion today let me know any followers
you get it's just so silly they follow
this
well there's a lot of a lot of
Christianity a lot of religions gay
people meaning depends on what you dial
it I get all that be but a lot of it the
the aimless faith in it when you look at
what everything's going down to be
realistic right it's gonna be tough for
you to find chin it doesn't matter we
think he's not before it wasn't that
long ago though wasn't like 70s or
something yeah Catholic Church treats
all consummated sacramental marriages as
permanent during the life of the spouses
and therefore does not allow remarriage
after a divorce if the other spouse
still lives and the marriage has not
been annulled
silly [ __ ] silly as [ __ ] so you deal
with a lot of stuff here for sure old
school [ __ ] yep dinner Deb yep yep I
want usually on something man if you and
I were married my life would be easy how
would we get along for Mary dude well I
beat the [ __ ] out of you and I'm lucky
I'm glad to know that you would just
tell the guy or anything about it you're
a natural bottom not beat you but you're
like sometimes you sent me I told you
that sometimes you send me stupid [ __ ]
like he's a doctor I went dude when you
send me stuff it's very rare I feel like
this I'm gonna hurt you right now yeah
yeah you just beat me up toss me around
below this choke me up a little bit well
done that to me before and memorize
throwing punches at your face and the in
the end the elevator and you have a need
and then you go if you do that one more
time I'm gonna [ __ ] you up and I go come
on alright that does the doors open and
I ran you caught me
he caught me like I ran out and I always
forgot he's fast I'm more like this man
spider-man yeah he [ __ ] like I just
here goosh goosh goosh he'd had it and
he just goes and he like one hand over
my shoulder the other under my arm and
just like crook Luna and you [ __ ] you
pull me in and it was it was a bad it
was bad time for bribe I well I would
take your shirt and I pulled over your
head and rip it and then just stop a
bunch of keep my knees up hard to finish
the ball bro
hard to finish a ball here thought it
was faster than I'll just oh yeah way
faster
I'll just alright don't say fight you
like a medicine ball if you ball up like
that what do you mean take like a 105
pounds 140 pound medicine ball with
psoriasis in spite picking up
just spiked you like throw my stupid
medicine ball hey a striped shirt no
because I'm holding on your eye and then
I cry loop on their the people around go
yeah no they hate your shirt ponder your
head pretty much it we have to figure
out what how we're gonna do this show
tomorrow probably no guess that early
huh talk about off here yeah I want you
I want to thank you guys for listening
in and you've said you'd beat me you may
find on my teeth and you made fun of my
shirt all of which I take offense to and
come at me bro bring your blind faith
and come at me pray to God you can beat
me up low now it works out for you you
know I know why what'd you do Night
Watch Guyanese Brady guy can beat me up
yeah and then try it tomorrow we'll see
what the big man thinks up dude I put my
hands I'll put my hands on your face one
a boy style tell you that let's see
because I did Taekwondo you know what we
should do you know we should do let me
keep you away with my feet god good luck
do that good luck with you good lighting
you and Ching gonna move around we got
to do it soon yeah a lot it's got to
happen I mean because of the fan
response that's not most and I'm making
t-shirts right it's gonna be just fun
it's not I'm not we're not hurting each
other on and by fun I mean insanely
boring um what are you gonna be bro
Brendan I'm glad you asked weak the [ __ ]
up I'm gonna be in this weekend I go to
house comedy in Minneapolis Minnesota
yes sir strolling the mall marched a
good time in yep Thursday Friday
Saturday I'm at good nights in Raleigh
North Carolina June 7 8 & 9 and I think
you know by now
besides Portland 21 22 23 helium we
added a second show well actually a
third show July 19 Thursday Thursday
your tickets July 19th time Friday
Saturday sold-out Thursday Ryan final
that yeah yeah Thursday gonna show deep
fat cake um for ticket and shop Bryan
Callen we're releasing the street
fighter Ken and Ryu Bryan Callen and
myself the shirt I'm wearing right now
on Arab releases Wednesday 5:00 p.m.
Pacific tv.com
I am in Pasadena Icehouse June 15th that
shows almost sold out one show one night
only June 15th at the ice house Pasadena
then I'm at Houston M
of June 22nd to 23rd two shows Friday to
Saturday all those shows are almost sold
out as well get to you Southie vk.com
get you some this is the final kid
we're out